[Musique]
salut la drogue est un sujet passionnant
extrêmement riche aussi bien du point de
vue politique que social philosophique
existentielle et c'est également un
sujet où il y a beaucoup d'idées reçues
beaucoup de préjugés à déconstruire je
n'ai donc pas me contenter de faire une
vidéo en fait je démarre une chaîne
entièrement consacrée au sujet cette
vidéo est présente sur les deux chaînes
le patient zéro et sa petite sœur le
sage doré ce nouveau projet se donne
pour objectif de lutter contre la
désinformation sur les drogues et leurs
usagers et usagers si le sujet vous
intéresse ou si vous avez simplement
envie de me soutenir n'hésitez pas à
aller vous abonner le lien de la chaîne
est en description allons-y
la première chose que je voudrais dire
c'est que la drogue est-ce qu'on appelle
un sujet de société c'est à dire qu'elle
occupe une place particulière dans
l'imaginaire collectif elle est associée
à toute une série de croyances relatives
à des pratiques des comportements des
dangers des classes sociales tout le
monde a une idée une image un sentiment
à propos des drogues c'est un sujet de
société aussi en ce sens personne n'y
connaît rien mais tout le monde a un
avis sur la question
en fait comme pour tous les sujets les
individus qui s'y penchent sérieusement
sont rares donc beaucoup d'idées fausses
circulent à propos des drogues
et le danger de la désinformation et
d'autant plus important que la drogue
génère beaucoup de fantasmes je veux
dire que ce qu'on s'imagine à propos de
ces substances et de leurs usagers et
usagers et souvent teintés de mystère
d'interdit il y a une forme de
fascination pas toujours très nette pour
la question c'est un sujet un peu tabou
aussi on peut remarquer que ça ne fait
pas sérieux prendre de la drogue
revendiquer sa consommation ou en
défendre l'intérêt jette immédiatement
une sorte de discrédit sur soi presque
chaque fois que j'ai tenté d'avoir une
conversation sur le sujet je me suis
heurté à des préjugés et à une forme de
refus de principe
il est important de comprendre que les
drogués forment une minorité sociale
c'est une catégorie de la population
opprimée par le système dominant il faut
rappeler l'évidence le fait de consommer
des drogues expose à tout un tas de
difficultés d'obstacles de contraintes
sans même rentrer dans le détail de la
situation législative il faut dire que
la société est largement toxicophobe il
faudra sûrement y consacrer une vidéo à
part entière mais disons pour le moment
que consommer de la drogue vous associe
immédiatement à des clichés méprisants
et parfois même très violents c'est une
discrimination par conséquent les
usagers et usagers ont tendance à faire
profil bas on les comprend mais ça
n'arrange pas notre problème puisque on
n'entend pas les concernés puisqu'on ne
s'intéresse pas à leur point de vue
l'imaginaire autour des drogues et
déconnecté de la réalité de l'usage les
représentations qu'on est saucisses
spontanément aux drogues ne viennent ni
des gens qui consomment ces substances
ni des gens qui rencontrent et
connaissent les gens qui consomment ces
substances alors d'où viennent ces idées
ces représentations il y a des films et
les séries bien sûr les documentaires
les émissions de téléracoleuse les
chansons la presse écrite bref
avant qu'on se lance dans le sujet je
crois que ce que je voudrais vous
demander sauf bien sûr si vous êtes
vous-même usagé ou usagère ou que vous
êtes déjà bien renseigné c'est d'essayer
autant que possible d'oublier tout ce
que vous croyez savoir sur les drogues
car à moins que vous ne soyez vraiment
penché sur le sujet il y a de très
fortes chances pour que votre conception
soit orientée par le traitement culturel
et médiatique auquel nous avons tous été
exposés tout au long de notre vie
et je vous invite d'autant plus que si
on s'y attarde un peu on se rend compte
que c'est un sujet fascinant important
et révélateur à la fois de la manière
dont la société fonctionne mais aussi de
la manière dont nous approchons
l'existence dans nos envisageons plus ou
moins consciemment le fait même de vivre
il me semble fondamental de prendre le
temps de faire l'effort de réfléchir au
fait même de vivre à la manière dont
nous expérimentons la vie à ce que cela
implique d'exister donc de ressentir de
penser à ce que nous valorisons à la
place que nous croyons se jouent dans
nos décisions or précisément prendre une
drogue volontairement c'est choisir de
modifier son état de conscience et
modifier son état de conscience c'est
une manière de mettre en perspective les
différentes manières que nous pouvons
avoir d'expérimenter l'existence ça
permet de voir sous un autre jour notre
expérience du fait d'être en vie rien
que pour cela les drogues forment un
objet d'étude fascinant pendant capacité
à ébranler la domination de notre état
de conscience ordinaire pour leur
capacité à nous libérer de notre
perspective quotidienne
peu de choses permettent aussi
efficacement aussi profondément et quasi
sûr commande de faire bouger notre
perspective sur l'expérience de faire
bouger notre manière de voir la vie
par ailleurs l'étude des drogues des
pratiques de son traitement social et
culturel permet d'éclairer certaines
dimensions de la vie humaine aussi bien
individuelle que collective
au niveau individuel on peut dire qu'il
existe tout un tas de moyens de modifier
son état de conscience et donc
différents états modifiés de conscience
pourquoi aime-t-on modifier son état de
conscience et pourquoi le tel manière
plutôt que de tel autre quelles sont nos
goûts en matière d'expérience et
qu'est-ce que c'est préférences
révèlent-elles sur nous sur la valeur
que nous donnons aux différentes
expériences qui jalonnent l'existence et
puis au niveau collectif il faut dire
que s'il existe tout un tas de moyens de
modifier son état de conscience la
société ne se comporte pas du tout de la
même manière vis-à-vis de chacun de ses
moyens or ces différences de traitement
ne vont pas toujours de soi pour quelles
raisons telles substance est-elle
acceptée était l'autre interdite
pourquoi celle-ci jouit d'une bonne
réputation quand est l'autre inspire le
mépris ou le dégoût
pourquoi certaines substance et donc par
extension certaines expériences
sont-elles davantage acceptées que
d'autres par la société comment en
sommes-nous arrivés à condamner
certaines altérations de conscience
la manière dont nous gérons
collectivement ces substances éclaire
certains aspects de l'organisation
sociale et notamment de notre système de
valeurs de notre rapport aux normes
parce que la drogue renvoie à une
expérience alternative c'est à dire
qu'elle permet l'accès à une forme
d'expérience qui diffère de ce que l'on
a l'habitude d'éprouver de ce que la
société identifie comme la norme comme
une expérience normale donc de ce que la
société nous encourage à éprouver par
extension la drogue renvoie donc à
l'idée d'un mode de vie alternatif
construire sa vie autour d'expérience
alternatives d'expérience que la société
ne considère pas comme normal cela a
pour conséquence de se retrouver en
décalage vis-à-vis du mode de vie
dominant
il faut reconnaître que la société
propose différentes manières de vivre
elle nous encourage à un adopter
certaines notamment en conférence un
statut et en offrant des privilèges à
celles et ceux qui les incarnent aussi
elle décourage d'en adopter d'autres
soit un directement par une simple
dévalorisation il suffit de penser aux
conditions de travail et au salaire des
infirmières par exemple soit directement
en intelligence des pratiques comme
c'est le cas avec les drogues
il est vrai que ces injonctions varient
d'un milieu social à un autre il existe
des milieux ou la consommation est
acceptée voire encouragée peut-être même
existe-t-il des contextes où il est mal
vu de n'avoir aucune expérience de
substance pourquoi la société
entretient-elle une telle ambivalence
dans le rapport au drogue pourquoi ce
mélange de fascination et de
condamnation
je dis que les drogues occupent une
situation ambiguë dans la société pour
deux raisons
d'un côté la drogue renvoie
majoritairement à des produits illégaux
associés comme on le disait à des modes
de vie alternatifs les consommateurs et
consommatrices sont pour la plupart
marginalisées du fait de leur
consommation
et dans le même temps le paysage
culturel est truffé de référence aux
drogues des films et des romans mettent
en scène des usagers et usagères les
chansons ventes les substances les
journalistes font des reportages
sensationalistes c'est donc à la fois un
truc marginal et un truc dont on parle
beaucoup c'est pas anodin parce que
comme on le disait ça génère beaucoup de
clichés
par exemple j'ai l'impression que
lorsque les films et les séries parlent
de drogue il n'y a que trois options
possibles pour le scénariste
1 la drogue est une occasion de
plaisanterie un personnage après quelque
chose de fort ou une trop grosse dose et
il va faire n'importe quoi oh là là
comme c'est rigolo il est ouvertement
ridicule et c'est souvent le regard des
gens sobre qui domine la situation qui
juste son état de conscience altérée
2 la drogue est un enfer consommer c'est
forcément perdre le contrôle sur sa
consommation sur sa vie et tomber dans
une spirale d'horreur
3 c'est la drogue comme transgression
comme aventure comme prise de risque
comme expression d'un désir
irrépressible de jouer avec le feu
jamais ne montre ton des consommateurs
et consommatrices qui gère des gens qui
ont un rapport équilibré à une substance
pour qui ça se passe globalement bien
une relation non spectaculaire non
dramatique à une substance qui enrichit
leur vie sensiblement
ou alors tout simplement comme quelque
chose d'anodin qui ne pèse pas sur
l'histoire
vous conviendrez que sa Biesse notre
imaginaire
un autre exemple de cette ambiguïté
c'est quand la société célèbre certaines
personnalités associée à une
consommation de drogue Johnny Hallyday a
évoqué à de nombreuses reprises en
interview sa relation avec la cocaïne ce
n'était un mystère pour personne et ça
n'a jamais semblé atteindre sa
popularité on pardonne à Johnny parce
que c'est une star et une star de la
musique qui plus est regardez ce cliché
par lequel France Info commence son
article c'est ce qui fait de la
consommation un truc acceptable un truc
cool et transgressif
son statut social lui permet ce coming
out d'usager sans prendre de risques ces
funérailles semblent attester que même
les plus hauts représentants de l'État
ne voyaient pas de problème particulier
à rendre hommage à un consommateur de
stupéfiants
aussi sans doute parce qu'il s'agit de
cocaïne chaque substance à son
imaginaire et Hollywood a beaucoup fait
pour glamoriser la cocaïne je ne pense
pas que Johnny aurait parlé avec autant
de confiance d'une consommation
d'héroïne une substance qui patine une
image plus sombre
autre exemple un type comme Beck BD peut
faire de sa consommation de drogue un
élément central de sa carrière il met en
scène la consommation comme une sorte
d'autodestruction d'artistes romantique
en un sens il a marketé son rapport aux
substances il en a fait une image de
marque donc à lui aussi on pardonne
on accepte que Steve Jobs est pris du
LSD dans sa jeunesse parce qu'on le
présente comme un entrepreneur
exceptionnel on voit donc cela comme une
expérimentation une aventure voir comme
quelque chose qui s'inscrit dans sa
démarche créative mais on trouve moins
d'excuses à l'étudiant en université qui
fument du cannabis et par on trouve
moins d'excuses je veux dire que la
société est plus prompte à le condamner
au sens propre comme au sens figuré
et je ne parle pas du traitement que les
médias réserves aux consommateurs et
consommatrices de crack
on pourrait croire que l'idée que l'on
se fait de la drogue dépend surtout de
l'usager si celui-ci a réussi alors la
drogue était soit un accident fortuit
soit quelque chose qui va avec un mode
de vie d'artiste soit une expérience
ponctuelle enrichissante
si au contraire l'usager a une vie
compliquée la drogue devient une des
causes fondamentales de ses échecs la
phrase il se drogue devenant synonyme de
il détruit sa vie
pour la plupart des gens la place
qu'occupe la drogue dans la vie d'un
usager ou d'une usagère et beaucoup trop
flou ça conduit donc à de grands
malentendus dont les drogués sont les
premières victimes c'est ce que l'on
voudrait des construire ici bon mais
alors commençons par le plus simple de
quoi parle-t-on quand on parle de drogue
[Musique]
la première chose à noter c'est
peut-être qu'il n'est pas évident de
donner une définition claire et précise
de la drogue je fais le pari que dans
l'imaginaire collectif les drogues ont
au moins deux caractéristiques elles
sont dangereuses et addictives
on consacrera une vidéo à cette question
alors pour le moment quand on nous
d'affirmer que cette association est
fausse
certaines drogues n'entraînent pas de
pharmacodépendance et certaines drogues
ne présentent pas ou peu de toxicité
pour le corps alors comment définit-on
les drogues soyons naïf et elles vont
faire un tour dans le dictionnaire
premier dictionnaire le Larousse c'est
généralement nuisible pour la santé bon
c'est pas hyper précis quant à santé
c'est encore une autre question pas
facile de savoir à quoi ça renvoie
exactement santé mentale fonctionnement
des organes on y reviendra plus tard
le est consommé en dehors d'une
prescription médicale est un peu
ironique quand on pense au scandale de
l'Occident aux États-Unis
on remarque que l'usage systématique de
stupéfiants est illustré avec un exemple
particulièrement sombre pour ne pas dire
caricatural
on note aussi l'usage métaphorique
madrogue c'est le café dans cette usage
ce qui est uniquement mis en avant c'est
le caractère addictif en ce sens on
réduit la substance à son pouvoir
addictogène ce qui ferait laissant une
drogue c'est sa capacité à entraîner une
dépendance ça entretient l'imaginaire et
le cliché de la drogue comme piège
l'idée que si tu essayes une fois tu es
foutu tes prises au piège tu pourras pas
t'en sortir
deuxième dico le Robert cette première
définition relan envisager une méthode
j'ai l'impression de l'avoir jamais trop
rencontré passons elle ne nous concerne
pas trop
ensuite on trouve le classique substance
toxique c'est quand même pas dingue de
précision à ce compte là le cyanure est
une drogue le white spirit le venin du
serpent à sonnette bref
stupéfiant nous n'avance pas trop non
plus ensuite on a une définition par le
droit un stupéfiant interdit ça nous
avance pas des masses enfin consommation
de stupéfiants les ravages de la drogue
c'est typique une définition qui ne
précise rien mais qui relie un cliché le
Robert estime informe pas mais participe
à l'imaginaire en place
troisième dico le Littré sans
commentaire si j'avais su que le dico le
plus traduit réac serait celui le moins
oppressif bon j'avoue que ça me fait un
petit plaisir
4 le dico de l'Académie française il
précise généralement au singulier ce qui
n'est pas anodin c'est vrai il vaudrait
mieux parler des drogues quand elles
sont différentes les unes des autres
on voit ensuite apparaître l'imaginaire
social sur le sujet on parle d'évasion
du réel et on met comme critère central
la dépendance enfin ce qui intoxique
l'esprit c'est un peu comme le
généralement nuisi pour la santé cela
part du principe que ce qui est bon ou
mauvais pour l'esprit est une affaire
régler évidemment il n'en est rien on
parle de sa plus précisément dans la
deuxième partie de la vidéo enfin le
CNRTL il y a un tout petit peu de mieux
avec le peu conduire qui sous-entend que
ce n'est pas forcément automatique mais
c'est bien peu pour combattre les
clichés les effets mentionnés sont quand
même pas bons et la suite est pire
je ne pense pas que enivrante
euphorisante ou hallucinogènes tempèrent
vraiment cette image terrifiante
faisons un petit détour par la
définition propose l'OMS on voit là une
approche bien plus prudente mais au
point où ce qui est écrit également pour
la nourriture et aussi d'ailleurs pour
la pilule ou toute prise d'hormones
puisque elles sont susceptibles de
modifier l'humeur
donc bon c'est quand même pas hyper
pratique
remarquons un truc en français drogue
désigne en premier lieu des substances
illicites en anglais drugs est employé
pour les substances illicites aussi bien
que pour les médicaments
le mot en France renvoie forcément à une
pratique cachée d'où le mystère qui
plane dessus en anglais on s'accorde à
associer les substances interdites à
celles les médicaments que la société
identifie comme des produits bénéfiques
c'est intéressant aussi parce que ça
rappelle le concept de pharmacon qui en
philosophie tant à désigner une chose
qui est à la fois un remède et un poison
une même substance peut être néfaste ou
bénéfique donc qu'est-ce qui détermine
si elle est néfaste bénéfique
précisément le contexte d'utilisation la
dose l'usagé usagère etc
c'est chouette de voir les choses ainsi
parce que ça évite de condamner de
manière unilatérale la substance ça va
plus loin que ce produit est dangereux
au lieu de croire qu'une substance est
intrinsèquement bonne ou mauvaise on
comprend que c'est notre relation de la
substance qui peut être bonne ou
mauvaise ça demande un petit effort de
réflexion ce qui est toujours bon signe
je voudrais faire remarquer au passage
qu'en anglais on a tendance à qualifier
d'ivresse issus des drogues comme Bing
high et que ça a une connotation bien
plus favorable que être défoncé être
souper high peut se laisser entendre
qu'on plane très haut comprendre la
hauteur sur sa vie sur ses émotions être
super défoncé évoque une destruction un
enfoncement quelque chose de sombre
bref si je devais donner moi-même une
définition je dirais ceci drogue
substance addictive ou non nuisible pour
certains organes ou non consommés pour
l'altération de l'expérience consciente
qu'elle permet voilà je crois que ça
permet à la fois de regrouper tout ce
qu'on appelle drogue et de mettre en
avant le sol dénominateur commun à tous
les usages si on met le critère de
l'addiction comme élément nécessaire on
perd certaines substances qu'il est
pourtant intuitive de classer parmi les
drogues comme le LSD ou la Salvia
divinoro et quant à l'idée que ce serait
nuisible pour la santé j'ai préféré
parler d'organe car la question de la
santé est très complexe c'est ce qu'on
va voir tout de suite
[Musique]
on a vu que la toxicité supposée de la
substance revient fréquemment dans les
définitions prendre de la drogue c'est
toujours immédiatement associé au fait
de mettre sa santé en danger mais il est
fondamental de rappeler que la question
de la santé n'est pas une affaire réglée
qui décide ce qu'est la bonne santé les
médecins sont peut-être des experts dans
le fonctionnement de notre corps et le
ces réactions à divers virus bactéries
etc mais ce ne sont pas les
prescripteurs officiels de ce qu'est une
bonne santé
Nietzsche voyait dans la figure des
prêtres une espèce d'autorité
insupportable qui entendait expliquer
aux gens comment ils doivent conduire
leur vie et qui décident à leur place de
ce qui est bon ou mauvais pour eux dans
son abécédaire on voit de lieu de se
faire la même critique vis-à-vis des
médecins et de fait on voit bien le
parallèle les médecins sont les
dépositaires d'une forme d'expertise qui
s'était tendue jusqu'à la conduite de
nos vies les médecins seraient garants
de ce qui est bon ou mauvais pour nous
manger moins gras ne buvez pas faites du
sport toute une série d'injonctions qui
découle d'une conception normée de la
santé
B et pour boisson dans cette abécédaire
et de le y déclare on peut boire autant
qu'on veut tant que ça n'empêche pas de
travailler aussi comprend-on que pour
lui son critère de santé c'est le
travail et non l'état de son foie si
boire ne n'empêche pas de penser à
l'heure il se considère être en bonne
santé et puis de l'autre préfère parler
de petites santé et de grande santé qui
sont des expressions plus ouvertes que
mauvaise santé et bonne santé on serait
bien dans le peine de définir clairement
ce qui fait ou défait la santé si mes
organes sont en parfait état de
fonctionnement selon mon médecin mais
que je me sens nul et que je n'ose me
lancer dans aucun projet suis-je en
meilleure santé que si mes poumons sont
encrassés et m'en fous amoché mais que
je n'ai jamais été aussi créatif
je ne veux pas trancher notamment parce
que je n'ai pas envie comme le fait de
le prendre un critère de productivité
pour évaluer la santé le fait est que
chacun devrait prendre le temps de
s'interroger sur ce qu'il perçoit être
une bonne santé cela pourrait revenir à
se demander à quelle puissance on
inspire car il y a d'autres puissances
que celle du travail on peut vouloir
développer notre capacité à imaginer à
rêver à aimer pourquoi ces indicateurs
là ne seraient pas de bonne mesure de la
santé pourquoi serait-il moins pertinent
que le fonctionnement de nos organes au
contraire je les trouve plutôt plus
convaincants en ce sens la question de
la santé est moins une affaire de
médecine qu'une affaire éthique au sens
propre car cela concerne notre manière
de ressentir d'évaluer nos pensées nos
émotions bref notre manière de conduire
notre vie et moi j'aurais tendance à
choisir comme indicateur le critère de
l'amour plus je suis capable d'aimer
plus je suis en bonne santé et si des
substances m'aident à aimer alors je
crois qu'il est bon pour ma santé que je
les consomme
nous ne devrions pas laisser la société
nous dire ce qui est bon pour nous nous
devons interroger la santé que l'on vise
et précisément c'est ce que font les
drogués ils s'invente une autre santé
que celle que les médecins défendent une
autre santé que celle que la société
promeut et pourquoi pas au nom de quoi
les empêcherait-on il y a quelque chose
de terriblement coercitif dans cette
interdiction de certaines substances car
la limite que dites-le sur l'alcool
concerne une substance légale donc oui
il y a des injonctions morales qui nous
invitent à boire raisonnablement mais ce
n'est rien quand on compare cela à
l'interdiction pure et dure des drogues
nous devrions toutes et tous avoir le
droit de définir ce qui constitue notre
idéal de santé nous devrions avoir le
droit d'explorer ce que cela peut
vouloir dire pour nous être en pleine
forme l'idéal de santé imposée par la
société convient peut-être à beaucoup de
gens mais voilà si on est un peu
différent si on a une sensibilité
particulière si on a d'autres
aspirations si on ne rêve pas de
réussite professionnelle si on ne veut
pas participer à la grande compétition
sociale s'il en est en quête d'autres
sentiments d'autres sensations que ce
que la culture dominante propose et
permet alors on est livré à soi-même
voire confronté à des interdictions à
des risques légaux
peut-être que l'alcool convient
parfaitement à Bob il travaille beaucoup
et le vendredi soir après une longue
semaine il a besoin de décompresser de
rire de se désinhiber alors il picole
avec ses copains et la société n'y
trouve pas grand chose à dire le
comportement de Bob est largement
accepté mais si Alice trouve que le
monde va trop vite si elle n'a pas
besoin de décompresser ou de se
désinhiber si elle n'a pas besoin de
rire et d'oublier son manager si elle a
juste besoin de ralentir de calmer son
esprit de s'apaiser peut-être qu'il
existe une substance qui pourrait jouer
ce rôle pour Alice mais elle n'en saura
rien car cette substance est illégale
car la société se refuse à lui offrir
cette opportunité
c'est le premier scandale de cette
affaire en interdisant des substances on
prive les gens d'une liberté
fondamentale celle de
s'auto-médicamenter se soigner apprendre
à identifier ce qui nous fait du bien
savoir s'administrer un soin voilà les
choses fondamentales dans le rapport à
soi les outils et techniques qui peuvent
rendre la vie plus facile mais dont on
nous a destitué en considérant qu'il
fallait remettre ce pouvoir à une
institution experte
interdire des substances qui offrent un
accès à d'autres manières de ressentir à
d'autres équilibres affectifs ces
contraindre la sensibilité des gens
c'est l'uniformiser en ce sens si l'on
considère que la santé d'une société
dépend de sa capacité à faire coexister
des points de vue divers à accueillir en
son sein une diversité de regards et
d'émotions alors interdire les drogues
est mauvais pour la santé sociale
[Musique]
dans la continuité de ce qui vient
d'être dit il faut souligner un autre
élément fondamental de la perception des
drogues qui réside dans un état de
conscience là encore mal définie la
lucidité
dans cette vidéo de la chaîne de
patience 0 on remarquez par exemple une
tendance à valoriser principalement les
activités mentales qui ont trait à la
connaissance on part du principe que le
plus important pour l'esprit c'est de
pouvoir distinguer le vrai du faux
aussi la société impose un
impérativement moral tacite notre
expérience doit être fidèle à ce que
l'on nomme réalité la réalité telle
qu'elle est décrite par la culture
dominante devient une norme qui s'auto
légitime la réalité c'est ce que la
norme appelle réalité et s'en écarter
c'est donc être anormal
avoir des expériences qui construisent
une réalité différente vous marginalise
automatiquement il y a donc
implicitement l'idée qu'être dans un
état normal c'est être lucide c'est
avoir accès à la réalité et par
extension prendre de la drogue c'est
fuir la réalité c'est vivre dans
l'illusion c'est ne pas être lucide
si on refait un tour dans les
dictionnaires pour lucidité voilà ce
qu'on trouve avoir toute sa conscience
voilà une expression beaucoup trop vague
si on s'arrête deux secondes si je veux
vraiment savoir ce que cela veut dire
d'être lucide et qu'on me répond c'est
quand tu as toute ta conscience je ne
suis pas plus avancé
on a ensuite fonctionnement normal des
facultés intellectuelles vous imaginez
bien que s'il faut définir ce qui
caractérise un fonctionnement normal on
n'est pas sorti de l'auberge et on
risque de tomber dans une définition
circulaire le fonctionnement normal
c'est quand on est du Sud
fonctionnement normal des facultés
intellectuelles ça semble dire dont le
fonctionnement correspond aux attentes
de la société donc là encore on rejoint
une forme d'uniformisation des
comportements en appelant lucidité le
fonctionnement normal on fait un
sous-entendu au lot de conséquences
respectez la norme c'est être dans le
vrai
ici avec le literie on tombe sur une
définition plus intéressante déjà en
disant que c'est la qualité de ce qui
est clair à l'intelligence on assoit la
valeur lucidité sur une expérience
subjective en somme selon la définition
du Littré il semble que seul l'esprit
peut se juger lui-même lucide dans le
même sens la définition du CNRTL offre
elle aussi une ouverture sympathique en
faisant de la lucidité la faculté de
voir et comprendre avec clarté et
justesse on laisse en suspens ce qui
définit une compréhension juste ce n'est
pas forcément ce qui convient à la norme
enfin qui juge des choses clairement
sans se payer d'illusions sans se payer
d'illusions qu'indique cette précision
qu'est-ce qui caractérise une illusion
et se payer ça veut dire si complaire
bref
ce que je voudrais retenir de toutes ces
définitions c'est qu'elle semble
soutenir l'intuition selon laquelle
notre état de conscience ordinaire est
un état lucide si l'on s'en tient ce qui
est décrit là la lucidité recoupe la
très grande majorité de nos états de
conscience or cette idée selon laquelle
je suis dans la vie de tous les jours
dans un état normal n'a rien d'évident
entre mon réveil et le café suis-je dans
mon état normal
quand je suis si concentré sur une tâche
que j'oublie le reste du monde mes amis
ma famille suis-je dans mon état normal
quand je rencontre quelqu'un qui me
plaît et que je pense à cette personne
12 fois par jour suis-je dans mon état
normal quand je regarde mon enfant jouer
et que ça me remplit de joie suis-je
dans mon état normal quand je ris avec
une amie au point d'en avoir mal au
ventre suis-je dans mon état normal
quand je danse pendant un concert
suis-je dans un état normal ou alors
c'est quand j'attends le métro que je
suis dans un état normal quand je fais
la vaisselle quand je fais les courses
je pose toutes ces questions à la fois
pour questionner l'existence d'un état
normal mais aussi pour mettre en lumière
que s'il existe nous ne lui accordons
pas toujours une très grande valeur nous
avons plutôt tendance à poursuivre des
moments émotionnels des moments qui
parce qu'ils atteignent une certaine
intensité colore notre expérience du
réel différemment donne une impression
de valeur ajoutée à l'existence on dit
parfois que ce sont ces moments qui font
que la vie vaut la peine d'être vécue
chaque fois que le se concentre sur
quelque chose chaque fois qu'une émotion
prend dessus s'impose comme l'émotion
dominante chaque fois qu'une pensée
intervient c'est la conscience qui bouge
change se transforme
et nous avons tendance à organiser nos
vies de manière à provoquer des
changements de conscience que nous
favorisons nous aimons certaines formes
que l'expérience consciente peut adopter
et nous n'aimons pas d'autres formes
il est intuitif de poser l'ivresse à la
lucidité mais cette opposition en plus
d'être réduitrices et maniciennes est
injuste pour les droguer
car cela masque ce qui rapproche les
usagers et usagers du reste de la
population
la plupart des gens ne cherchent pas
activement la lucidité la plupart des
gens idéalise pas l'état normal la
plupart des gens passent leur temps à
viser des configurations affectives
spécifiques
je me demande si on ne doit pas cette
approche binaire qui oppose lucidité et
ivresse à l'alcool comme si on faisait
spontanément cette association ne pas
être dans son état habituel c'est ne pas
être lucide c'est comme être ivre ou
être bourré comme si l'ivresse d'alcool
était devenu la référence les talons de
l'État altéré de conscience
peut-être que ne pas être dans son état
habituel peut au contraire être
équivalent à être davantage du Cid je
crois qu'on a évacué l'idée que
peut-être certaines substances peuvent
altérer la conscience pour rendre plus
lucide et non pas plus ivre qu'elle
donne accès à des états mentaux qui ne
sont pas nécessairement brouillon ou
illusoire mais au contraire éclairant et
précis
d'ailleurs Charlotte 8 un écrivain du
siècle dernier auteur entre autres du
pays de l'éclairement préférer qualifier
certaines substances
qui évoque immédiatement une expérience
illusoire
[Musique]
si l'expérience de la drogue d'un accès
à d'autres états mentaux et donc à une
autre perspective sur la réalité il faut
noter que ce déplacement de point de vue
peut être plus ou moins durable la
modification peut être temporaire voire
une durée que le temps de l'expérience
c'est faire de la drogue une bulle une
parenthèse c'est sans doute le cas de ce
qu'on appelle les consommateurs et
consommatrices occasionnels l'expérience
peut être très plaisante très intense
mais rapidement nous retrouvons notre
perspective habituelle sur le monde
c'est un certain type de relation à la
substance en pointillés
et puis il y a le type de relation qui
engage des modifications durables de
notre point de vue sur l'existence sans
doute peut-on parler de droguer dans ces
cas-là c'est la définition que je
propose ici elle est volontairement
minimale un drogué ou une droguée c'est
quelqu'un qui par l'entremise une
relation régulière à une ou plusieurs
substances a durablement modifié la
forme de son rapport à l'existence
de quelle modification parle-t-on et
bien je crois qu'il s'agit de
transformer les valeurs les désirs les
peurs les croyances on pourrait imaginer
un gigantesque égalisateur comme pour
les chaînes hi-fi du siècle précédent
on avait déjà utilisé cette métaphore
dans la petite vidéo sur le sens de la
vie d'ailleurs elle va complètement dans
le sens de ce qu'on raconte ici
sur cette égalisateur on y trouve tout
ce qu'il est possible de ressentir
consciemment et chaque indicateur de
l'égalisateur est composé de plusieurs
sous-indicateurs bon évidemment là c'est
pas complet c'est juste à titre
indicatif notre égalisateur est
constamment en train d'évoluer cet
égalisateur bouge tout au long de la
journée il y a des gens chez qui bougent
très peu dans la journée ou d'un jour à
l'autre d'une semaine ou d'un mois à
l'autre et il y a des gens chez qui au
contraire ça bouge beaucoup chez qui il
y a d'importantes variations
pour chaque personne il y a comme un
delta de ce qui est considéré comme
normal c'est une sorte de moyenne pour
Alice par exemple tant que les valeurs
se situent entre telle limite basse et
telle limite haute elle considèrera
qu'elle est dans un état relativement
ordinaire pour Bob c'est autre chose
c'est seulement quand on sort de ce
delta de ses moyennes qu'on atteint des
pics ou des chutes qu'on ressent cela
comme un état extraordinaire
lorsqu'on prend une drogue l'égalisateur
bouche significativement souvent cela
permet justement de sortir de ses
propres moyens
il n'y a pas que les drogues qu'il faut
sortir de la moyenne passer un entretien
d'embauche le premier baiser avec une
personne qu'on aime les exemples ne
manquent pas peut-être qu'un usage
prolongé des substances permet de
changer nos moyens durablement de faire
bouger le delta
ça c'est chaque Delta affectif d'Alice
sans prendre de substances et là c'est
en tant que consommatrice d'une
substance
pourquoi cela poserait-il le problème
tout le monde aimerait avoir le contrôle
de légalisateur alors pourquoi juger
celles et ceux qui consomment des
substances pour le faire bouger c'est
une manière tout à fait censée de
poursuivre des états de confiance chaque
substance tant à produire un certain
état et chaque personne qui consomme
apprend à connaître le type d'État qui
l'intéresse la drogue nous force à nous
positionner vis-à-vis de ce que nous
qualifions d'expérience intéressantes
vis-à-vis de qu'on considère qu'il est
bon de vivre on n'est pas tous d'accord
là-dessus et c'est pas un souci mais il
faut au moins le reconnaître nous ne
valorisons pas tous les mêmes états
mentaux on peut aimer une substance
parce que son effet est encouragé par la
société certains aiment le café parce
que ça rend plus productif et la société
récompense les gens productifs
l'histoire de la pause café est
d'ailleurs intimement liée à l'histoire
économique et industrielle
au contraire on peut aimer une substance
parce qu'elle nous aide à suivre un
système de valeurs différent de celui
que notre environnement nous impose
qu'une substance nous aide à échapper à
des normes et des injonctions sociales
n'en fait pas un échappatoire une
illusion un refus de la lucidité une
fuite ou je ne sais quoi cela veut
simplement dire qu'on voit dans une
substance une alliée pour nous aider à
construire un rapport à l'existence qui
soit plus riche et plus équilibré
relativement à nos besoins et objectifs
il n'y a aucune raison de croire qu'un
état de conscience est plus proche de la
vérité simplement parce qu'il est plus
fréquent ou plus répandu
il n'y a que des expériences que l'on
soit concentré sur la route ou pris dans
un film que l'on soit en train de rêver
que l'on ait bu que l'on fasse l'amour
que l'on prenne une substance ce sont
toujours des expériences et il est
permis de comparer des expériences entre
elles certaines sont plus agréables que
d'autres certaines sont plus compatibles
avec les attentes de la vie sociale que
d'autres mais aucune ne peut prétendre
être la vraie expérience normale ce
qu'on appelle état normal renvoie
simplement à l'état le plus banal le
plus habituel ça ne constitue pas une
valeur en soi et on devrait encourager
les gens à explorer les états
alternatifs en prenant toutes les
précautions possibles bien sûr mais
parce qu'il y a plein de choses à y
apprendre parce que ça offre une
nouvelle perspective sur nos états
habituels parce que ça donne du recul
sur les états de conscience que notre
culture encourage c'est tout de même
très simple de prendre de la distance
vis-à-vis des injonctions que l'on
reçoit plus ou moins consciemment tous
les jours
on est régulièrement bombardé de valeur
soyez ceci faites cela c'est ça qui est
cool réussir sa vie ça ressemble à ça
consommer des substances permet
d'interroger le bien fondé de ces
injonctions cela permet de les regarder
d'un autre œil de les déconstruire
atteindre des états de légalisateur
différent de ceux que la vie génère
spontanément c'est se donner une chance
de penser autrement d'envisager d'autres
croyances d'autres valeurs et quand on
voit ce que produit le mode de vie
dominant on se dit qu'on a bien besoin
de faire un pas de côté on encourage les
gens à être compétitif narcissique
productif originaux on les invite à
consommer à voir l'accumulation de
richesse comme l'indice d'une vie
réussie la consommation de substances
permet un décalage vis-à-vis de ce
modèle en interdisant les drogues on se
coupe d'un formidable moyen pour
questionner notre rapport à la vie aux
affects que l'on veut valoriser pour
interroger ce qui caractérise une vie
réussie et je crois qu'on a vraiment
besoin de ce type de remise en question
c'est une chose de ne pas être intrigué
par le pouvoir de ces substances c'en
est une autre de vouloir les interdire
pour autrui pourquoi un tel refus sinon
parce que la société tend à réprimer ce
qui conduit à remettre son
fonctionnement en cause
petite parenthèse je veux croire que
cette précision n'est pas indispensable
mais au cas où si certains parmi vous
pensent que la société condamne les
drogues parce qu'elle représente un
danger pour le consommateur et pour les
autres je crois qu'il suffit de voir le
traitement réservé à l'alcool pour
comprendre que ce n'est pas le cas
malgré les différents dangers qui
impliquent la consommation d'alcool
c'est si est globalement encouragé pour
autant il faut tout de même préciser que
l'imaginaire autour de l'alcool n'est
pas homogène il est beaucoup moins bien
vu de boire et d'être sous quand on est
une femme ou quand on est pauvre la
manière dont la société traite un buveur
ou une usagère de drogue n'est jamais
indépendante de son statut social une
injustice de plus
je crois que c'est toute la société qui
patient de cette situation les
usagers et usagers en premier lieu bien
sûr qui ne peuvent mener leur vie comme
ils l'entende mais l'état aussi d'abord
parce que la guerre contre la drogue la
prohibition et les politiques
répressives ça coûte un pognon de dingue
et en plus ça ne marche pas ensuite
parce que la prohibition implique des
produits de moins bonne qualité donc
plus dangereux
et puis les gens en général d'abord
parce que certaines substances
interdites ont un réel potentiel
thérapeutique ou antalgique on passe à
côté de traitement moins invasif et
moins coûteux ensuite parce que comme on
le disait on a privé les gens d'un moyen
très puissant pour explorer leur
conscience et apprendre à se connaître
il faut plaindre celles et ceux qui ont
peur des substances celles et ceux que
la société a convaincu de se méfier des
drogues que les drogues sont mauvaises
que l'expérience n'a pas de valeur que
ce n'est qu'une illusion on leur a volé
tout un pan de leur existence on les a
persuadé que l'état de conscience idéale
et celui qui est le plus conforme aux
attentes énormes sociales que la bonne
vie c'est être en accord avec les
valeurs dominantes c'est de voir le
monde comment nous le présente qu'une
bonne vie est une vie confortable et
prévisible au chaud dans nos habitudes
mentales je les plains sincèrement comme
je plains celles et ceux qui décident de
se lancer quand même dans l'aventure et
qui doivent redoubler d'efforts et de
prudence dans un monde idéal la société
communiquerait intelligemment sur les
différentes substances offrirait un
cadre préventif efficace pour
accompagner sans danger celles et ceux
qui veulent explorer leur conscience
[Musique]
les drogués sont des gens qui comme tout
le monde tendent vers des états
affectifs qu'il valorise ils ont juste
la malchance de trouver cet état via des
substances qui peuvent impliquer des
contreparties que ce soit en termes
d'addiction d'accoutumance de toxicité
pour certains organes et de vivre dans
une société où les moyens permettant cet
état sont souvent illégaux ce qui
suppose donc qu'il n'existe aucune
infrastructure pour leur permettre
d'atteindre leur but en toute sécurité
aussi les dangers qu'on associe
spontanément en substances sont en
réalité davantage dû au mode de vie que
la substance elle-même et ces modes de
vie difficiles précisément à cause de la
prohibition c'est un sacré cercle
vicieux on interdit des substances des
gens ont envie ou besoin de ces
substances l'interdiction rend la
consommation difficile et dangereuse le
manque de structure est d'accompagnement
dans la consommation conduit à une
précarisation des usagers et usagers et
à la fin les pouvoirs publics déclarent
regardez ce que font ces substances elle
rend les gens précaires il faut leur
faire la guerre
il y a beaucoup de mythes qui traînent
sur les drogues il va falloir qu'on
prenne le temps des déconstruire et
c'est en premier lieu l'idée que drogue
= danger qui nous faut remettre en cause
il y a plein d'activités dangereuses
elles pénismes la boxe conduit une
voiture utiliser certains outils on ne
s'empêche pas de faire tout ça parce que
c'est dangereux mais en limite les
risques et que fait-on pour limiter les
risques pas par exemple on apprend on
fait attention on s'entraîne on n'y
pense pas assez mais se droguer cela
s'apprend aussi on a prévoit des
substances et leurs effets et on apprend
à gérer sa consommation à optimiser les
expériences à comprendre notre relation
à ces états de conscience par exemple il
y a la question de la dose et ce n'est
pas une histoire banale de quantité
c'est une affaire plus complexe que ça
c'est une signification la dose il y a
dans l'esprit du drogué un espace
concerné par la question de la dose un
espace qui appréhende la dose qui la
pense l'évalue l'interroge de manière
tout à fait analogue à l'esprit du chef
en cuisine qui dose son assaisonnement
ou à la musicienne qui dose la hauteur
de la note au peintre qui dose le
mélange des couleurs aux amoureuses qui
dosent l'intensité de leur baiser
et c'est aussi en un sens qu'on appelle
une technique de soi c'est une manière
de se rapporter à soi d'apprendre à se
connaître tu as fini notre compréhension
de nos affects
et oui c'est en surprendra peut-être
beaucoup mais la drogue est une affaire
très sérieuse très précisé méticuleuse
j'espère que cette vidéo vous aura
convaincu et que vous allez vous abonner
dans la foulée à bientôt